hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today we're going to talk about the
Caucasian languages the Caucasian
languages are named after the Caucasus
Mountains which are situated between the
Black Sea and the Caspian Sea and more
or less serve as a geographic border
between Europe and Asia the Caucasian
languages are spoken in and around the
Caucasus Mountains the caucasian
languages are actually not a language
family they are a regional grouping of
languages and within that regional
grouping there are several language
families the families normally included
within the regional grouping our car
trillion which used to be referred to as
South Caucasian northwest caucasian and
northeast caucasian there are other
language families present in the
caucasus including indo-european semitic
Turkic and mongolic but they're
distributed over a wider area and have
indigenous speakers outside of the
region these particular three language
families are indigenous only to the
Caucasus which is what makes them
members of this group of languages car
trilliant has around 5.2 million
speakers mainly in Georgia around 4
million of them speak Georgian in
Georgia of course but also by a minority
over the border in Turkey Azerbaijan and
Russia the other car trillion languages
armed ingre lien laws which has spoken
mainly on the southeast coast of the
Black Sea and Turkey and spun spun
branched off from proto car villian
around 5,000 years ago and the other
branch split into Kart or Georgian and
zon around 4000 years ago
then zan began diverging into Ming gree
lien and laws in the 7th century when
their speakers were separated into
different territories mean gree lien and
laws are the closest car trillion
languages and have some degree of mutual
intelligibility however it's worth
noting that many or even most speakers
of Ming Grillin laws and spawn the ones
who live in Georgia that is also speak
Georgian and Georgian has traditionally
been the written language for all court
villian speakers so of course those
bilingual speakers can also understand
Georgian Northeast Caucasian languages
are spoken by around 3.8 million people
mainly in Dagestan Chechnya Ingushetia
and parts of northern Azerbaijan the
most widely spoken languages include
Chechen with 1.5 million speakers of are
with 1 million lesbian with around
800,000 and English with around 500,000
northwest caucasian languages are spoken
by around 2.5 million people mainly in
Abkhazia the khabar dinoball Korean
Republic the Karachi Cherokees Republic
and Adi gaya there are 4 or 5 main
languages kabardian or East Circassian
with around 1.6 million speakers Adi gay
or West Circassian with around half a
million speakers many of them in Turkey
in the Middle East AB cos with around a
hundred and ninety thousand speakers and
Abaza with around fifty thousand I
should point out that the Circassian
people also known as the Adi gay people
consider both the east and west branches
to be the same language and refer to all
varieties as Adi gay and they are
mutually intelligible with each other
there's also the extinct Ubah language
which was quite an intriguing language
as we'll see later the North West and
the North East Caucasian languages are
thought by some linguists to be branches
of a single language family the North
Caucasian languages but this is still
controversial car trillion is widely
accepted to be unrelated to them yet
despite the huge diversity within these
three language families there are also
numerous shared features due to mutual
regional influence in other words the
sprach both affect common features all
Caucasian languages are continental
languages meaning that consonants are
heard with more frequency than vowels in
cart villians specifically there are
lots of big consonant clusters for
example goonie
this means they peel us of course the
meaning is nonsensical but it's an
example of how big the consonant
clusters can potentially get the
Caucasian languages are also known for
their rich consonant inventories in
other words they have lots of distinct
consonants the degree to which this is
true depends on the language family and
on the individual language the core
trillion languages have comparable few
distinct consonants 28 for Georgian and
34 laws that's similar to the 28 of
Arabic and the 36 of Russian note that
I'm talking about
consonant sounds not written consonant
symbols the Northwest and northeast
Caucasian languages have much larger
inventories especially in northwest
caucasian the now extinct uber language
had over eighty distinct consonants and
Circassian has fifty to sixty consonants
depending on the dialect that may sound
impossible how could there be so many
consonants well it's in large part due
to secondary articulation if a consonant
has secondary articulation that
basically means that it's pronounced in
two different places in the vocal tract
at the same time like two consonants at
the same time one primary consonant and
then one extra consonant pronounced
along with it that secondary
articulation might be palatalization
with the tongue raised towards the hard
palate labial ization articulation with
the lips valorization the back of the
tongue raises towards the velum go
authorization the closure of the glottis
and so on one type of consonant with
secondary articulation that's common to
the caucasian language families is
ejected consonants in an objective
consonant the glottis at the back of
your throat is closed and the larynx is
quickly raised which raises the air
pressure in the mouth this creates a
popping sound when the primary consonant
is produced all of the languages have
eject of stops
let's hear some ejectives in georgia uh
uh sir and an example word charlie
meaning water in all of the languages
stops have at least a three-way
distinction between voiceless aspirated
stops voiced stops and ejective stops /
/ / here's an example word in chechen
meaning bridge listen for the slight
popping sound that accompanies that
sound they Circassian in the northwest
caucasian family has ejected fricatives
as well for a total of at least 10
dejected or even more depending on the
dialect
oh [ __ ]
sure and the word meaning black
another common feature is contrast
between velar and uvular stops for
example in chechen cun-cun agglutination
the word agglutination comes from the
latin word a glutton ra meaning to glue
together that gives us an image of how
words are formed in agglutinative
languages words are created by gluing
together a linear sequence of morphemes
with each morpheme representing one
piece of meaning that's slightly
different from fusional languages in
which those additional morphemes can't
contain multiple pieces of meaning
here's an example from Chechen mullah
this is a verb in the infinitive form
meaning to drink moe Dola this means to
start drinking this suffix creates the
inceptive form to change to the past
tense we can first remove part of the
ending and replace it with this mal
delete this means started drinking in
the recent past but it's something the
speaker has no direct knowledge of
mulled ELISA this means started drinking
and I saw it happen with the suffix ER
ah the verb is in the witnessed past the
speaker witnessed the action happening
this type of feature is called
evidential tea all three families have a
feature called evidential tea which
means that verbs are inflected to show
whether the speaker has evidence of the
action or not this feature entered court
billion through Turkic influence though
in the other families it likely existed
before contact with Turkic speakers
especially in the northwest caucasian
family
caucasian languages also generally
display sov word order though this is
not equally true for all families or
languages georgian for example has sov
but also SVO depending on what the focus
of the sentence is with the focus coming
before the verb ergative 'ti all three
families display or give 'ti though the
court villian language mean Brillion
does not you may be wondering what the
heck is a Givet II sometimes I still ask
myself that same question it's a feature
that's quite rare among the languages of
the world some other argot of languages
include Basque Kurdish Hindi and Tibetan
basically in an ERG ative language the
subject of an intransitive verb and the
direct object of a transitive verb are
treated as the same they are in the same
case the absolutive case let's give an
example in fake English will pretend
English as ergative he sleeps him loves
XI you can see that the object of this
sentence is in the same case as the
subject of this sentence why that's so
weird
think of it like this these two pronouns
are in the same case because they both
fully receive the verbs action in an
intransitive verb the subject undergoes
the action in a transitive verb the
object undergoes the action so they are
both in the same case the absolutive
case the subject of the transitive verb
is treated differently because it
doesn't receive the action it's in the
ergative case yeah but that's in fake
English right here's an example in
Georgian meaning the student went
student in mérida this sentence means
the student wrote the letter student
mutt
ideally dadada so you can see that
student in the first sentence is in the
same case as letter in the second
sentence student in the second sentence
is in a different case Georgian has
mixed purgative ax T with the feature
not appearing in all tenses or with all
verbs but other caucasian languages are
more consistently ergative features
shared by two of the three families as I
said before the Northeast Caucasian and
northwest caucasian languages are
thought by some linguists to be part of
a single language family referred to as
north caucasian so they have some shared
features that car Trillian doesn't have
or does have but two
lesser degree I already mentioned that
they have much larger consonant
inventories than car trillion for
example they have laryngeal consonants
these are consonants pronounced in your
voice box at the back of your throat
your pharynx or your glottis Northeast
Caucasian has the most for example in
chechen Oh a couple of example words
that meaning custom or habit and um
meaning swamp or marsh and in Circassian
uh it's easier to hear these sounds in
an actual word loop one this means Bay
or Gulf
the only laryngeal sounded car trillion
is hot like the H sound in English they
also have labia lized consonants which
means the consonants are produced with
the lips rounded at the same time for
example in Circassian and an example
word offset they also exist in chechen
but in chechen they are non phonemic
they are allophonic which means they're
not perceived as separate consonants
merely as variations of an existing
consonant
North Caucasian languages often use
non-finite verb forms verb forms that
don't indicate any tense like
participles in English such as reading
these are normally used as modifiers
instead of relative clauses northwest
caucasian and car Trillian also have
some things in common that Northeast
Caucasian doesn't have one major example
is Polly personal verbs Polly personal
verbs can have inflections for more than
one person in the sentence including the
subject direct object and indirect
object here's an example in Georgia
quatrain and this means they will show
us this is the direct object marker
meaning us this is the pre verb which
helps distinguish certain tenses this is
the root meaning show and this is the
subject marker meaning they and in
Circassian yes - this means I gave it to
him or her this is the indirect object
marker meaning him or her this is the
subject marker meaning I this is the
root meaning give this indicates the
preterite form in other words the past
tense
this indicates the verb is in the
affirmative here the direct object is
left out because it's clear from the
context but sentences that included are
also possible the genetic links of the
Caucasian languages to other language
families are completely unknown which
has led to some interesting theories
some people believe that car trillion or
the North Caucasian languages or both
are related to Basque that's because of
some shared features like purgative 'ti
and pali personal verbs the Bhaskar
trillion connection is not widely
believed anymore but there are still
some who think Basque might be very
distantly related to the North Caucasian
languages
Danae Caucasian this is a proposed
language family spanning Eurasia and
North America which includes North
Caucasian gurus ASCII in Pakistan
sino-tibetan Jana Saiyan the Noddin a
languages and the VAS conic languages
including Basque this theory is not
widely accepted and remains very
controversial the huge linguistic
diversity of the Caucasus as well as the
difficulty in clearly determining the
connection between the different
languages there makes it a fascinating
region to examine caucasian languages
also have quite different free
from languages elsewhere which makes
learning about them a mind-bending
experience the question of the day what
do you think about some of the unique
features of Caucasian languages that I
talked about in this video do any of
these features appear in your language a
big special thanks goes out to my
patreon supporters especially these ones
right here on the screen they're my top
tier patreon supporters and that's why
their names appear in the video patrons
of different tiers get different
benefits such as access to the private
LAN focus online community check out
patreon.com/lenguin
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice stay
[Music]
you
[Music]